quiero empezar por decirles que tengo 25
años
y bueno ustedes dirán y eso que ok los
pongo en contexto hace no mucho tiempo
estaba en el casual cafecito con mi
grupo de amigas y es un tipo de grupo de
amigas donde casi no nos vemos entonces
nos teníamos que poner al día no íbamos
una por una
empezando a contar nuestras penas
nuestros pesares y todo y cuando me
llegó el turno de hablar a mí
híjole algo se apoderó de mí yo sentí
que estaba como en pleno confesionario y
me solté fue más o menos así
saben que estoy harta estoy lista porque
no tengo ni idea de qué está pasando
en mi relación laboral con mis jefes con
mi trabajo siento que aunque le he hecho
todas las ganas del mundo no doy una
en mi relación con mi novio estamos bien
pero a veces no siento para dónde vamos
para adelante sí para atrás en un punto
gris a veces se siente así por la
monotonía
en mi futuro
cada que me conecto a redes sociales veo
que alguien se está casando se está
comprometiendo
está planeando su maestría en españa
resumiendo nos el ticket de un vuelo yo
no tengo ni idea de que estoy haciendo a
dónde voy
finalmente siento como que nunca en
ningún lado
y una de mis amigas no voy a decir que
la mas criticona pero deduzcan a ustedes
estaba en la esquina de la mesa viéndome
así de
o sea si way pero tipo porque te
preocupas o sea es porque estamos
pasando por la crisis de los 25 si sabes
no
una parte de mí les voy a admitir se
sintió súper ofendida porque cuando uno
escucha esta palabra incluso en la
cuestión industrial empresarial es caos
total todo está en la ruina y si dije ok
si estoy un poquito
exagerando pero no estoy en la ruina y
adicionalmente no sé si soy solo yo
corríjanme si me equivoco pero siempre
que escucho la palabra crisis junto con
una edad yo lo asocio directamente a
algo así un hombre o una mujer por no
decir chavo rucos porque para que verdad
que se empiezan a pintar el pelo de
algún color divertido que se empiezan a
tatuar y poner cosas divertidas empiezan
a hablar en onda
que se compra en el coche que mal pueden
pagar pero es que lo necesito entonces
esa ventaja crisis me sacó mucho de onda
porque dije no no no no no amiga yo
tengo 25 no 40
y también les debo de confesar que otra
parte de mí se sintió muy aliviada dije
que padre todo lo que me está pasando
tiene una explicación científica
psicológica entonces en cuanto yo pisé
los 26 en cuanto los cumpla voy a estar
feliz de la vida se acabó el problema y
bueno no pasaron muchos días después
cuando estaba teniendo una conversación
algo similar ahora con mi novio mi novio
para ponerlos en contexto es actor
entonces platicando y así se los voy a
citar lo mejor que pueda yo no soy la
actriz en la relación obviamente pero me
dijo
amor sin y
estoy valiendo
siento como que no estoy sobresaliendo
en mi carrera como actor como quisiera
para este punto para esta edad ya me
gustaría mínimo haber sido un víctor
uribe un luis gerardo méndez ya ni se
diga leonardo dicaprio pero algo veo que
todo el mundo está ganando premios que
se está yendo para otros lados y yo
estoy estancado profesionalmente siento
también que no tengo lo que debería
tener para este punto de mi vida las
casas las propiedades las inversiones y
no lo tengo
ya después de haberse como desahogado y
yo también así con cara de me dijo pero
sabes que amor si niño es por la crisis
de los 30
por la crisis de los 30
no solo no es a los 40 como yo pensaba
no solo me dijeron a mí que yo estaba en
crisis ahora resulta que también hay de
los 30 o sea te la pasas toda la adultez
en crisis o que no y aparte o sea de
haber una crisis del kinder 3 una crisis
de por dar una charla está todo el
tiempo nos la vivimos en crisis y media
la tarea personal de empezar a
investigar al respecto dije no es
demasiada coincidencia tengo que
investigar que psicólogos dicen cuáles
crisis son verdaderas a partir de cuándo
empiezan de cualidades como lo válido
como se puede manejar cómo se pueden
evitar algún manual para no pasar por
esto
y entre que sabe me sigan bueno el otro
día me metí a disney plus y vi una
película que a mí me encanta que es de
disney pixar y se llama 'los increíbles'
quien de aquí la visto levante la mano
por favor ok no se ve mucho con esto
pero varios y los que no porque salió
hace mucho bueno está bien para los que
no les voy a explicar un poquito de qué
trata esta película
los increíbles se resume en la crisis de
la mediana edad del padre de la familia
protagonista y él se llama robert par
robert park era un superhéroe guapísimo
tenía el coche que quería la novia que
quería el amor el aplauso y el
reconocimiento de todo mundo por sus
actos heroicos era el top de los
superiores
por una o por otra cuestión roberto tuvo
que dejar de ser superhéroe y se
encontró con una cruda realidad perdón
que después nos muestran es un hombre
que tiene un trabajo en el que no es
para nada feliz
se le está cayendo el pelo
engordo no tiene las posesiones y las
cosas que él pensó tener como de lujo
ya mencioné que engordó porque
definitivamente es lo peor de todo para
mí y bueno
y ese hombre es infeliz
luego la película nos empieza a platicar
que se le presenta la oportunidad de una
nueva oferta laboral como superhéroe y
con esta oferta laboral él retoma la
motivación las ganas de seguir adelante
su vida es otra vez color de rosa
entonces baja de peso se compra un coche
nuevo
hace mil y un cosas ejercicio se pinta
otra vez el pelo la ropita nueva incluso
su esposa se llega a preocupar mucho
dijo
aquí huele mal este hombre me está
poniendo el cuerno
porque claro que personas después de los
40 50 s se siente tan motivado de
repente de la nada es porque le está
pintando los cuernos a la mujer
entonces ya entrando un poquito en el
tema me gustaría decirles que de esto de
lo que me hablaron mis amigas de lo que
me hablaba mi novio y de lo que nos
habla la película de los increíbles
realmente se llaman crisis normativas y
las crisis normativas son situaciones
donde nosotros vamos a tener hitos en la
vida situaciones donde se va a poner en
riesgo lo más importante para nosotros
de hecho el término crisis de la mediana
edad o crisis del cuarto de siglo x del
medio siglo etcétera lo propuso por
primera vez un psicoanalista canadiense
llamado helio jacques lo propuso en un
artículo titulado la muerte y la crisis
de la mitad de vida con esto decía que
el hombre pasa por situaciones muy
tristes a la mitad de su vida
inevitablemente les voy a poner un
ejemplo
ustedes saben que el paso del tiempo es
inevitable no perdona a nadie y el curso
de la naturaleza
tampoco
para los 40s y 50s
cualquier persona va a empezar a perder
a todos aquellos que lo acompañaron en
el camino por la muerte de su madre de
su padre
de sus hermanos mayores incluso
también si seguiste la norma social para
los 20 sea vas a tener muchos años de
casado estamos digo para los 40s si te
casaste a los 20 es para tus 40s vas a
tener muchos años de casado entonces
para este punto de tu vida mucha gente
decide si continuamos hasta que nos
vayamos a morir otro en a la cosa
adicionalmente para este punto también
ya tienes muchísima experiencia laboral
en una sola empresa o en varias si te
quedas sin trabajo o si empiezas a
perder todo eso en este punto crisis
total
y volvamos un poquito al tema de lo que
decía la película les decía robert era
un hombre entre sus cuarentas y
cincuentas que no se sentía a gusto que
no tenía ninguna motivación ni nada y
las crisis en los cuarentas y cincuentas
realmente se generaliza no se engloban
en estas dos palabras
arrepentimiento y nostalgia
arrepentimiento por lo que no hice
porque no me compré eso cuando tenía
tiempo porque no invertí cuando podía
porque no compre eso si en ese momento
podía o porque no ahorre más despilfarre
muchísimo y la nostalgia como le pasó a
robert mis mejores tiempos ya pasaron
mis mejores tiempos ya pasaron entonces
ya me voy a morir que me queda
por eso decimos que la gente entre sus
cuarenta y cincuenta seres chaveta sea
loca y se empieza a comprar el coche que
siempre se prometió si vamos a comprar
el lamborghini tinto tal ya me voy a
morir
si me voy a actuar aquí un dragón porque
en total ya me voy a morir y todas esas
cosas empiezan a suceder por eso pero
ahora que les expliqué ya no juzguemos a
nuestros estimada audiencia que están en
los 40s ahora vámonos a los 30 o algo
similar al ejemplo que les decía de mi
novio en los 30 sucede algo muy chistoso
y es que spoiler en los veintes tenemos
incertidumbre y en los 40s como les
mencioné pues es esta cuestión del
arrepentimiento y la nostalgia todo esto
sumado en los 30s más una enorme enorme
presión social les explicó y no me
dejarán mentir si para los treintas
cualquier persona pero particularmente
las mujeres no se han casado o no han
tenido hijos está la abuelita con el
comentario
hombres hay muchos andar el que sea pero
ya te dijo como no vas a tener hijos
hay mejor congela sus óvulos hija o algo
o sea lo peor lo peor no y al hombre
digo no generalicemos hombre o mujer
pero particular en particularmente a los
hombres que están enfocados en el éxito
profesional si para los 30s no han
escalado al puesto directivo de su
empresa se ponen mal si no han comprado
el coche la propiedad tienen todo el
dinero para educar a sus hijos como
quisieron les va mal porque es una
presión social enorme de estarse
comparando con otros hombres que están
mejor que ellos
y ahora si lo que me pasa a mí en
nuestro grupo a nuestra edad no estoy en
los temibles 25 la mitad
y siempre nos han dicho siempre nos han
metido la idea de que si a los 25 o sea
los 20 no tienes definida todas las
grandes cosas de tu vida las decisiones
estás mal con quién te vas a casar dónde
vas a estudiar por qué vas a estudiar
eso en qué vas a invertir
etcétera etcétera de hecho me acabo de
acordar una frase muy chistosa que les
quiero decir y cito textual para que
nadie se me ponga triste pero guillermo
del toro decía yo nunca me había sentido
tan
como en mis veintes
sentía que ya se me ha ido el tren que
ya se me olvidó el avión pero yo estoy
aquí para decirles que les sobra un
mucho de tiempo ya me aventé una
grosería dos no un mucho el tiempo
y la verdad es esa ahora probablemente
con esto que les voy a decir les cambia
totalmente el curso de la plática pero
se los tengo que decir todos los días lo
queramos o no estamos pasando por una
crisis en menor o mayor escala
lo contamos o no lo contamos que si me
chocaron que si llegué tarde que si me
regañaron en la empresa que si mi esposa
se enojó por esto por aquello todo el
tiempo estamos en crisis
y si todo el tiempo estamos en crisis
entonces la crisis se vuelve algo normal
y si estar en crisis es algo normal
entonces se radica por completo la idea
de las crisis me explico
y papá una vez me dijo y me acuerdo muy
bien
me vio teniendo una de mis múltiples
crisis por algo que me sucedió y toda
nerviosa y me dijo hija si yo tuviera tu
edad más de experiencia el temple y el
carácter que tengo hoy
te juro que me comería el mundo entero
obviamente después me regañó y me dijo
un montón de cosas como son los papás
verdad pero en ese momento entendí que
no se puede llegar a ese carácter a toda
la experiencia sin haber pasado por las
crisis no nos podemos saltar el camino
las crisis son algo inevitable
y sobre todo es algo precioso porque si
tenemos este enfoque de poner en la
cuerda floja y en otra perspectiva todo
aquello que nos importa nuestra familia
nuestros matrimonios
nuestro trabajo solamente para mejorar
aprender y encontrar imaginación
suficiente para superarlo entonces
estamos del otro lado le definamos
nuestras crisis como esos momentos que
ponen en la cuerda floja lo que nos
interesa solo para reenfocar ver las
cosas de manera distinta y sobre todo
para aprender de ello porque amigos lo
queramos o no y se los digo de corazón
estamos de buenas o de malas al respecto
las crisis están aquí para quedarse sin
crisis no creces y aparte las crisis el
día de hoy son la nueva normalidad
[Aplausos]